it's like so long
foreign
okay so I want you just to listen right
now okay we're gonna have the public
defender I know Dad look at me take a
deep breath take a deep breath I know
just take a deep breath for me okay I'm
gonna have your public defender come
back and talk to you okay and then we're
gonna go out and we're gonna do your
hearing any can you hear me
do you need a second
take a deep breath
okay so your product a friend will come
back and talk to you you understand that
okay and then we'll go out for your
hearing okay there is news media out
there okay when you walk out you'll see
a piece of black tape on the floor all I
need from you is to stand on that piece
of black tape face the judge the judge
only and just listen okay you're a
public defender or your attorney is
going to do all the Talking for you
um they'll say that you have the right
to remain silent and I advise you to use
that okay because everything in there is
reported so I want you again just to
stay in the book at the judge judge only
don't turn to the media don't turn to
anybody in the audience that you may
know listen to the judge and let your
public defender do the talking for you
okay if you have any questions for us
okay
that's right
you need help
Maybe
okay okay
[Music]
it's fine
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
very very temporary
activists now it's not
man
[Music]
okay
um
[Music]
yeah that's like one by one
we're out
so no issues all right Miss Norman
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
friends
[Music]
videos
questions
[Music]
alive I'll write down a bit of support
hey dude
foreign
um as Bondurant he is 32 years old
being married is employed
he indicates that his relatives
go across Dorman may act as cosigners
for him
at this time your honor he would submit
to the court
that a bottom of 75 000 reported
conditions being open
and you Mr called to do a job Mark
Jacoby Turner and kind of crossover on
behalf of the State uh
we are at this point I'm going to let Mr
gast
on
morning
judge we've got law enforcement this
here today our office has been involved
uh lots of different worlds involved
with law enforcement throughout
yesterday uh afternoon and evening all
the way through this morning
and the facts I have for you at this
point are as follows
the trauma that this man has inflicted
on his family
the Community Law Enforcement
First Responders and all of the rest of
us who have any idea what's going on
here is unspeed
there's been a whole mission in this
case Jersey case is still new virtual
discovering facts
but the evil war of what we know is
impossible to process
in an act of just
incomprehensible cruelty for father to
stand before you wind up with three
young boys
be executed in his own homes of horizon
they were ages three four and seven
an act of desperation to save her
children the mother
at some point
grabbed the gun the father was wielding
to attempt to protect them
we know that one of the boys was able to
flee
into a field and move home
and again we know from his admission
father runs it that way down
back to the property
and executed him in front of witnesses
mother was
shot their hand in her attempt to
protect her children
judge I asked the court and sending this
Bond
to just begin
as we'll match Their Fear
this is the man
every day they woke up
looking to for protection love
guidance and all things
man they trust more than any other
person on Earth
person their life on to keep them safe
and harm
it was their world and was their
Guardian
and he execute them this whole building
we know that from his position
and that same admission judge he has
committed
one of the most monstrous craving
cowardly acts of ever be our Misfortune
scene
to make things even more disturbing
judge this was no haphazard act Again by
then admission he planned the events of
this day
this did not happen on a run
he's confessed what I believe is the
worst crime the police I hope
see in my life
I think it's the worst fat pattern
really comes before this
judge
it's important
of course no and bond we're going to
request today
for the court to understand
Paramount County deputies
Monroe Township Fire EMS and other First
Responders greatly respond to the scene
where they don't know what's going on
they did not know what they're facing
and they come into a
a scene no one can ever or no law
enforcement training no training for any
time prepared it's easy to forget
that these are men and women with
families
children feelings emotions
they're not some automaton performing a
delegated function to people
they're required to give
CPR to gunshot children
three four and seven-year-old children
they held these boys in their arms
knewing
knowing there was nothing they could do
to save
how long do those Stars last
the day you wake up from that
you're healed how do you unsee
such an abomination
Bond factors this court needs to
consider today
are set forth and criminal if they're
46. nature and circumstances the crime
charged and specifically whether the
defendant used or had access to real
weapon including the serious as the
effects
it's the most serious offense that we
have on the bookstore
for serious offense so the nature of the
crime charge is the worst crime that can
be charged
do you have access to a weapon yes
obviously
the weight of the evidence against the
defendant at this point judge would be
stand here with the full admission of
the defendant that also goes to the
confirmation of the defendant's identity
and Witnesses on the scene
did see at least
part of what happened
next the court is to consider the
likelihood of this person would return
the court of the bond or issue
again this is the most heinous crime
with the most severe Point into the wall
that we presented
that alone
would be a major factor in discouraging
a person in front of availing himself to
this court or any other
thought to flee and the likelihood of
flight is great in the state's opinion
the danger he poses the community is the
fact that this court can consider and I
think with the facts in front of you
judge we can't name a person
that poses a greater threat to the
community
as his prior record goes judges fairly
minimal who is charged with domestic
violence in 2010.
he is not to my knowledge on probation
Community Control
judge
the facts of this case
are hopefully like no other we will ever
see
when this case gets indicted and
imported economically as I am certain
that ain't no bond appearing will be
held and I
that would be granted but at this point
this juncture we're going to ask this
court to issue a bond we've never asked
for before I'm going to ask for a bond
of 20 million dollars
[Music]
thank you uh date for preliminary repair
political inner hearing judge is 6 26.
no objection problem
the preliminary occurring will be set
for June 26th at 1 pm
at this point time bot is going to be
set in the amount of 20 million cash or
Surety
anything else at this time Mr guest no
good news
okay
nothing at this time
turn your left to face the wall
[Music]
foreign
okay
hand down with your side houses Cuts
release
do not move it
foreign